mais toi c'est combien plus ces 270
euros
oui moi 124 estelle elle a payé plus de
300 plus la surprise a été de taille il
y a quelques jours les habitants de
château chinon ville ont reçu leur
feuille d'imposition locale d'une année
sur l'autre
une hausse qui se chiffrent parfois à
plusieurs centaines d'euros entre les
frais qu'on peut avoir
occasionnellement plus toutes les
charges qu'on a donc le loyer les
courses
l'électricité l'eau etc c'est vrai que
ça fait un sacré budget encore à
dépenser en plus leurs associés de
transparence nous tenions à vous
informer de cette situation indépendante
de notre volonté
on a reçu une lettre une aide qui nous
disait que ben on aurait eu en gros une
augmentation des impôts mais on
s'attendait quand même pas une
augmentation pareil quoi à l'origine de
ce changement de fiscalité la fusion des
intercommunalités imposée par la loi au
1er janvier dernier avec pour
conséquence l'harmonisation des
compétences voirie jeunesse centres
sociaux sont maintenant pris en charge
par la communauté de communes bien sûr
les impôts communautaires ont dû
absorber ces nouvelles charges et en
parallèle les communes ont été invités
puisqu'elle n'avait plus à les financer
a baissé d'autant leurs impôts et nous
avons formalisé sa de manière très
transparente par la signature avec
chaque commune d'impact financier et
fiscal
charge ensuite aux communes d'appliquer
ou non ce pacte à château chinon ville
dans une volonté d'assainir les finances
la municipalité a préféré ne pas
compenser l'évolution de la taxe
communauté sap a été un choix c'est pas
un choix c'est jamais un choix d'aller
demander à des concitoyens de payer plus
d'impôts une année que l'année
précédente c'était une obligation pour
équilibrer le budget et pour se laisser
une petite marche de manoeuvre pour les
investissements à venir
les habitants espèrent encore faire
fléchir cette position est limité leurs
factures une pétition circule et un
rassemblement sera organisé vendredi à
15h30 devant la mairie
la trame assez du château